vous mettez le dentifrice avant ou après
avoir mouillé votre brosse à dents je
veux dire il ya une réglementation pour
ça est ce que quelqu'un sait ce qu'il
faut faire
non oui bon d'accord je m'invente un
petit peu des problèmes surtout
qu'aujourd'hui je vous parlais de série
donc rien à voir je vous parlais de
séries américaines c'est pas que j'aime
pas les séries françaises
non attention commissaire voix
j'avais un truc là à merci super c'est
vrai que quand tu t'ennuies un petit peu
une bonne série franchement sato clip
bien par contre je me suis imposé une
règle à moi même ne jamais commencer une
série 1 les américains font des séries
avec que beaucoup trop de saison comme
ça et je sais pas m'arrêter
tiens et si je regardais lost
[Musique]
d'ailleurs c'est tellement simple de
regarder des séries aujourd'hui hop tu
télécharges en quelques clics
bim bam boum tout nous saison et tout le
temps d attention je ne télécharge pas
ah non
j'achète les dvd vous n'avez rien vu
vous avez tout oublié vous mettez votre
dentifrice avant de mouiller votre
brosse à temps alors moi les séries
américaines j'adore sa part contient un
petit truc qui me chiffonne et
scénariste martin petit plan sucette
quoi exemple dont la première saison de
prison break
un des personnages à qui on coupe la
tête mais qui revient dans les saisons
d'après les scénarii se sont quand même
dit ça passe tout seul c'est ça ça fait
longtemps qu est ce que tu te dis ah ça
la tête
ah non mais c'est rien c'est rien du
tout inquiète pas j'ai mis un peu de
scotch de la patience et c'est réglé ya
juste la tête
il tombe un petit peu mais c'est un
détail
voilà qu'un problème normal le problème
c'est qu'en france on ne peut pas parler
de série c'est un sujet tabou
enfin pas de série et pour une raison
simple c'est pour éviter ça râle quand
jack quitte lille pour se marier avec le
docteur sheperd c'est incroyable comme
femme qui pouvaient pas pourquoi tu me
regardent comme ça
j'ai dit un truc qu'il fallait pas ça
toi aussi tu regarde des séries mais
c'est trop génial
alors alors tu peux partager ma vidéo
sur facebook et rejoindre ma page
waouh temps le point commun moi j'ai
envie de te dire vas sur cyprien point
fr pouvoir toutes mes autres vidéos
c'est tout